thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to get
20
off an annual premium subscription
[Music]
we're nearing the end of our fourth
season of journey to the micro cosmos
and over that time we've been able to
see microbes through all kinds of lenses
literally thanks to james our master of
microscopes
for the rest of us on the micro cosmos
team it's been really cool
to not only see the footage that james
has recorded
but also see the journey that he has
been on with the microscopes
themselves now we have been able to make
this journey because of
all of you and the support you have
shown to this channel by watching and
commenting
and sharing with others or even and
especially by supporting us on patreon
we've all been on this journey together
so let's look back on
where it's taken us and also get a peek
at where we're going in the future
in the first season james started out
with two microscopes
one was a microscope that he assembled
himself from different parts for
under 200. the other microscope was a
modic ba 310
that he received from a microscope
company shortly after we started this
channel
and these microscopes give us such
beautiful footage thanks in part to the
different techniques that
james used with them whether that was
bright field or
phase contrast or dark field or some
other technique to manipulate the light
shining on the micro cosmos
but these microscopes also had their
limits so we were really excited to see
what would happen
when james bought a new microscope
before the start of our third season
the zeiss axioscope 5. this new
microscope came with higher quality
objectives which are the lenses on the
bottom of the microscope
as well as prisms that made it possible
for us to look at microbes
with differential interference contrast
microscopy
a technique that sharpened their
features and made them
seem more three-dimensional on our
screen
we have videos exploring these different
techniques and
microscopes so if you want to learn more
about them we recommend checking those
out
because light is much weirder
than it seems but we wanted to do a
quick summary for reasons that are
probably very clear from the title of
this video
we have upgraded our microscope
the zeiss axioscope 5 was a very
exciting
change but it was also an expensive one
so when james bought it he was only able
to get two objectives
a 20 times objective and a 63 times
objective
adding that to the 10 times
magnification the eyepiece gives let us
magnify our samples
by 200 times and 630 times respectively
which is not bad but a standard
microscope usually comes with five to
six objectives
for a reason the microcosmos is full of
things both
small and large to observe and there is
not a one-size-fits-all objective that
you can use to observe everything
so one of james's priorities was
expanding his set of objectives
so that he could have the flexibility to
see the micro cosmos
at more scales and thanks to his recent
upgrade
he's now gone from a set of two to a set
of six that range from five times
to 100 times and that gives us a
magnification
range from 50x to 1000x
since i've gotten my own prototype of
the micro cosmos microscope that we are
manufacturing thanks to backers of our
kickstarter
i have been amazed at how important it
is to have this variety of options
and how much time i spend on the lower
magnifications
as well as going deeper so without
further ado
let's introduce these different
objectives by looking at a ciliate
called tetrahymena that's taken up
residence
in a rotifer exoskeleton
[Music]
with the 5x objective we can see
little dots swimming in what used to be
empty space but it is hard
to make out the details here when we
move to the 10x objective we can start
to make out shapes of the tetrahymena
and more of the emptiness around them
but it's difficult to see the
exoskeleton
then as we start to go up in
magnification the details of the
exoskeleton become clearer
it's cool to see more and more of these
details as we zoom in
and especially when we get to the 100
times objective
which gives us 1 000 times magnification
you can make out so much of the insides
of the tetrahymena
that they look like bags of very
resilient
bubbles
[Music]
here's another cilia called a pseudo pro
radon that
james looked at through all of these
objectives
at first it just looks like a little
green thing floating around
and knocking into stuff but as we go up
in magnification
we can start to make up the subtle
undulations of its body
which shifts the different shades of
green
and as we look even closer the green
itself takes on a new life
revealing the perimeters of the
individual algae
inside the pseudo-pro-radon revealing
those details
inside the tetrahymena and the
pseudoproradon
comes at a cost we can't see as much of
the world around them
whether that's the emptiness around the
root of her exoskeleton
or the objects that the pseudoproradon
keeps bumping into
whether or not you need those details
depends on what you are trying to learn
and what we are trying to show and
that's why
having the flexibility to look through a
wider range of objectives is such an
exciting
upgrade for us objectives are our
gateways into the micro cosmos and we
are excited to have
all of these new scales to look at
we've also made some other upgrades so
we can revisit techniques we used on
older microscopes
like a polarizer because who doesn't
love this
shiny iridescent stuff but we're not
just sticking with what we've known
thanks to this upgrade
we've got a whole new way to look at
cells fluorescence
microscopy and we are so
excited for this one the techniques
we've highlighted so far are
clever manipulations of white light a
mixture of many visible wavelengths of
light but
in fluorescence microscopy instead of
illuminating our sample with that
mixture we choose a specific
wavelength of light that light is called
the excitation light because
well it excites certain structures based
on their chemistry
and those excitable structures then emit
some light
of their own the emission light will
then travel
back through the objective get past
barriers that filter out the excitation
light
and then show up in our eyes as vivid
color with our upgrade we have four
different wavelengths of light that we
can use
for fluorescence microscopy and the
parts of the sample that we see
fluoresce
will depend on which light we use
in this footage we're looking at the
pseudo proradon that we saw
earlier only this time it's being hit
with 385 nanometer light
the red we see is the fluorescence from
natural structures
this is called autofluorescence the rest
of the organism is dark
because it did not respond to that 385
nanometer light
making the color all the more vibrant
but the power of fluorescence microscopy
is not
just finding fluorescent structures that
exist in nature
chemists and biologists have developed
all sorts of ingenious techniques to
highlight different parts of cells
using fluorescent dyes and proteins
james is working on building up his
arsenal of fluorescence microscopy tools
and techniques
so that soon we'll be able to dive even
deeper
into the micro cosmos to seek out things
that have been hidden from us before
uncovering the unseen world inside
the unseen world that surrounds us
thank you for coming on this journey
with us and thank you to brilliant
for sponsoring this episode brilliant
features
hands-on courses in science math and
computer science
and there you can learn everything from
astrophysics to programming with python
if all that sounds like a lot to choose
from and you need help figuring out
where to start brilliant
has a bunch of curated learning paths
where they've compiled courses into
categories like
science foundations and college
mathematics
so you can make sure you're taking all
the courses that will help you get
where you want to go on your learning
journey if you're interested in learning
more you can get 20
off an annual premium subscription at
brilliant.org
microcosmos the names that you're seeing
on the screen right now
they are our patrons on patreon and they
are the reasons that we've been able to
stay on this journey for so long
and also explore our world in such new
and exciting ways we are so excited to
be using
the resources from your patronage to do
really cool things
so that we can see deeper into our world
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you